cuber entered a not-guilty plea and we
asked that the court in the interest of
justice and to avoid prejudice sever the
two separate incidences for trial and we
actually answered ready to proceed today
with the first incident for trial we are
shocked outraged and absolutely
dumbfounded that the district attorney's
office has wasted the taxpayers money
resources in time in charging Cuba
with these two incredulous cases you
have seen the first case which is
revealed in a 10 second video clip where
Cuba is being alleged to have groped a
woman's breasts yet the video does not
reveal anything along those lines and
after over a hundred and twenty days of
trying to develop a case having
interviewed seven different individuals
gone through twenty five hundred videos
and established a DNA assessment of the
alleged accuses dress which revealed
four different DNA's the district
attorney was still unable to proceed to
trial we then saw this morning that they
added one other accusers charged to this
indictment which is even less credible
than the first one and we ask you the
media to insist that the district
attorney release the video of the second
accuses claim which will once again show
that absolutely
no criminal conduct was engaged in by
Cuba